les portes sont encore close mais dans
cette boutique de l'espace saint quentin
à montigny le bretonneux
les vendeuses se prépare à la
réouverture de leurs magasins on a été
très content de l'annnonce du président
parce qu'on avait vraiment très envie
d'ouvrir le magasin on a reçu toute la
marchandise tout la mecque
la nouvelle collection toutes les idées
cadeaux noël on a préparé la vitrine aux
mannequins sont habillés donc on a très
hâte mais la réouverture des boutiques
ne va pas sans un protocole sanitaires
très strictes
le président de la république dans son
allocution télévisée a décrété la règle
des huit mètres carrés par personne
contre 4 avant leur confinement
on est limité à 30 clients maximum dans
l'enceinte du magasin
donc on fera bien attention jusqu'au on
a toujours quelqu'un à l'accueil du
magasin on sera bien attention pour
filtrer le maximum de clients pour
éviter d'avoir en trop de monde car la
période de noël est la plus importante
pour les commerçants dans la librairie
le pavé du canal le mois de novembre et
décembre représente 25% du chiffre
d'affaires de la nuit tous les samedis
on les compte forcément
donc même juste un week-end avant un
samedi c'est pas c'est pas neutre non
plus sur notre chiffre d'affaires donc
oui c'est une très très bonne chose que
ça vous dès le 28 novembre 50 personnes
maximum pourront rentrer dans la
librairie en même temps ce qui équivaut
à 12 mètres carrés par client on va
compter les personnes qui vont entrer et
on va donc compter aussi des personnes
qui vont sortir on va se protéger nous
aussi avec des périmètres de sécurité
prend des pierres et de sanitaires
autour de nos accueils et tout ce qui à
tous les points de caisse aussi il va
falloir qu'on fasse des des files
d'attentes qui soit conforme aux
contraintes mais les clients seront ils
au rendez vous le responsable de la
librairie y croit je pense que va y
avoir du monde rue parce qu'il ya une
forte attente aussi de la part des
clients des lecteurs et puis les cadeaux
de noël vont commencer à se préparer
maintenant
donc oui je pense que va y avoir un peu
de monde samedi les 19 salariés seront
en tout cas sur le pont dès samedi 28
novembre matin tous les commerces
devront fermer leurs portes à 21h les
cinémas théâtres et musées pourront
rouvrir le 15 décembre les restaurants
et des salles de sport le 20 janvier
si la situation sanitaire le permet